כולנו צריכים את היכולת לתקשר מידע פרטי בלי לפחד שמישהו מאזין. אבל לתכנן
מערכת חסינת תקלות לזה זה לא פשוט. בפרק היום של Qiskit in the Classroom, נדבר על איך
משהו שנקרא הפצת מפתחות קוונטית יכול
לעזור. ברוכים השבים ל-Qiskit in the Classroom. בסדרה הזו, נכסה נושאים שאתם עשויים להיתקל בהם בקורס
אוניברסיטאי הקשור למחשוב קוונטי. כל סרטון מגיע עם מודול אינטראקטיבי שמקושר בתיאור, אז
תבדקו את זה. היום, ניכנס לעולם הקריפטוגרפיה הקוונטית. קריפטוגרפיה היא חקר
הטכניקות לתקשורת מאובטחת. זה חשוב להפליא להרבה חלקים בחיים שלנו. כל פעם שאתם משתמשים
בסיסמה כדי להתחבר לאתר, שולחים תשלום דיגיטלי, או כשממשלות משדרות מודיעין צבאי, הכל נעשה
דרך פרוטוקול קריפטוגרפי כלשהו כדי שמצותת לא יוכל ללמוד את הסודות שלנו. אבל יש כאן מתח. איך
אנחנו מוודאים שהאדם שאיתו אנחנו רוצים לתקשר יוכל להבין את ההודעה שלנו, אבל אף אחד אחר לא?
היסטורית, קריפטוגרפים המציאו הרבה פרוטוקולים שונים כדי לנסות להפוך את ההודעות שלהם לחסינות
מפני מצותתים ככל האפשר. לפעמים שני הצדדים שרוצים לתקשר בצורה מאובטחת מסכימים מראש על
קוד שבתקווה כל כך מסובך שמצותת לא יוכל לפצח אותו. אבל כפי
שאנשים כמו Alan Turing ושוברי קודים אחרים בזמן מלחמה הראו לנו, אפילו הקודים הכי מסובכים אפשר
לפצח. באופן אידיאלי, היינו רוצים לשלוח הודעות שמוצפנות בצורה כזו שאין בכלל שום תבנית
ושום דרך שמצותת יוכל להבין בלי שיהיה לו גם מפתח סודי אקראי שרק השולח והמקבל
יודעים. אבל אז אנחנו פותחים את עצמנו לפגיעות חדשה. איך אפשר לשלוח את המפתח הזה ולהיות בטוחים ש
אף אחד לא יירט אותו? ב-1984, Charles Bennett ו-Gilles Brassard המציאו
שיטה לשלוח מפתח בצורה מאובטחת עם ביטים קוונטיים, שנקראת היום BB84. התכונה המרכזית של הביטים הקוונטיים
האלה או qubit-ים שמאפשרת את הפרוטוקול הזה היא שהם מצייתים לעקרון אי הוודאות. אי אפשר למדוד
מערכת קוונטית בלי להפריע לה. היום, נתחיל עם דוגמה לקוד קריפטוגרפי פשוט. אחר כך
אראה לכם איך הפצת מפתחות קוונטית ועקרון אי הוודאות מאפשרים לנו להשתמש בהצפנות כמעט בלתי
ניתנות לפיצוח. אעביר אתכם דרך פרוטוקול BB84 בפירוט ולבסוף נריץ אותו על מחשב קוונטי
אמיתי. קודם כל, בואו נתחיל עם משחק שאולי ראיתם בעבר שנקרא קריפטוגרמה.
מקבלים רצף של אותיות שנראות אקראיות, אבל בעזרת הידע שלכם על תבניות בשפה
האנגלית, אפשר להחליף אות אחת באחרת כדי לתת משמעות להודעה. הנה דוגמה. זוהי הודעה
סודית עם צופן החלפה פשוט. אז, כל ה-R-ים מייצגים אות אחת, M-ים מייצגים
אות אחרת, וכן הלאה. אם אתם רוצים לנסות לפתור את זה בעצמכם, עצרו את הסרטון עכשיו.
מסתבר שההודעה הזו הוצפנה באמצעות צופן מאוד פשוט שנקרא צופן קיסר שבו
האלף-בית פשוט מוזז במספר מסוים, במקרה הזה 9. אז A הופך ל-J, B
הופך ל-K, C הופך ל-L וכן הלאה. ככל שההודעה ארוכה יותר, כך קל יותר
לראות את התבנית. אז, עם הודעה ארוכה כמו זו שקיבלנו, צופן קיסר או כל צופן אחר שפשוט
מחליף אות אחת באלף-בית באחרת הוא די פשוט לפיצוח. דרך יותר מאובטחת להצפין הודעה סודית
היא עם מה שנקרא פנקס חד-פעמי. עם פנקס חד-פעמי, אפשר להזיז כל אות בהודעה בהזזה
שונה. פשוט צריך לספר לחבר שלכם מה ההזזה הייתה בכל אחת כדי שיוכל לפענח את ההודעה.
רשימת ההזזות הזו נקראת המפתח או הפנקס. זה נקרא פנקס חד-פעמי כי משתמשים בו פעם אחת ואז זורקים.
אם משתמשים בו יותר מזה, יצוצו תבניות שיכולות להפוך את ההצפנה לניתנת לפיצוח. עם הצפנת
פנקס חד-פעמי, גם ההודעה המוצפנת וגם המפתח בנפרד הם סתם מחרוזת אקראית של שטויות. אבל
כשמחברים אותם יחד, רואים הודעה סודית צצה מתוך הרעש.
בואו נעשה דוגמה קצרה. נגיד שכבר יצרתי ושלחתי לחבר שלי את הפנקס החד-פעמי הזה שבדרך כלל כתוב
בבינארי. ואז אני רוצה לשלוח את ההודעה I love quantum. אז הייתי מצפין את ההודעה
באמצעות הפנקס החד-פעמי ככה. קודם ממירים את האותיות בהודעה שלנו לבינארי. כל אות A עד Z
מתאימה למספרים 1 עד 26 כתובים בבינארי. אז A יהיה 0 0
0 1 B 0 0 1
0 C 0 0 1 1 וכן
הלאה. ואז רווח יהיה פשוט כל אפסים.
אז ככה נראית ההודעה. מצפינים את ההודעה על ידי ביצוע XOR בין כל ביט בהודעה לבין
הביט המתאים לו בפנקס החד-פעמי. אם לא ראיתם XOR קודם, זה
ראשי תיבות של exclusive or. ה-XOR בין שני ביטים יהיה אחד אם רק אחד
מהביטים הוא אחד ואפס אם שניהם אפס או שניהם אחד. אז חמשת הביטים הראשונים בהודעה המוצפנת
הופכים ל-1 0
0 1 1. אשאיר את שאר ה-XOR-ים שתעשו בעצמכם. אבל הנקודה היא ש
ההודעה הזו היא עכשיו סתם מחרוזת אקראית של אפסים ואחדות בלי שום תבנית. היא לגמרי בלתי ניתנת לפענוח על ידי מישהו ש
אין לו את הפנקס החד-פעמי שהשתמשנו בו להצפנת ההודעה. אז, מה למדנו עד כה? חלק משיטות ההצפנה
טובות יותר מאחרות, וחלקן ניתן להסיק על ידי אדם חכם שמחפש תבניות בהודעה
המוצפנת. אבל מפתח באמת אקראי שמזיז כל אות בהודעה סודית בכמות אקראית שונה לא ניתן
להסקה כי אין שום תבניות בהודעה. הפגיעות היחידה בתכנית כזו היא לוודא
שהמפתח שהשתמשו בו להצפנת ההודעה לא נופל לידיים הלא נכונות. כאן נכנסת הפצת מפתחות
קוונטית לתמונה. באמצעות qubit-ים, Bennett ו-Brassard המציאו דרך לשני צדדים להסכים על מפתח ו
להיות בטוחים למדי שצד שלישי לא האזין בסתר. פרוטוקול BB84 הזה קצת מסובך, אבל
נעבור עליו צעד אחר צעד. להסבר הזה, בואו נחזיר את החברים הוותיקים שלנו, Alice ו-
Bob. הפרוטוקול מתחיל בכך ש-Alice מכינה סט של qubit-ים לשלוח ל-Bob. ה-qubit-ים האלה מכילים את
המידע שיהפוך לפנקס החד-פעמי המשותף שלהם או המפתח. Alice קודם מייצרת שני רצפים אקראיים באותו
אורך. אחד הוא רצף אקראי של אפסים ואחדות והשני הוא רצף אקראי של X-ים ו-Z-ים שמייצגים את
הבסיס שבו היא תכין את ה-qubit-ים שלה. אז היא תכין כל qubit במצב קוונטי לפי
השילוב של הבסיס וערך הביט שמוצגים בטבלה הזו. אז אם הביט הוא אפס והבסיס הוא Z, היא
תכין את ה-qubit במצב אפס. או אם הביט הוא אחד והבסיס הוא X, היא תכין אותו במצב מינוס. אם
אתם לא בטוחים מה הבסיסים והמצבים הקוונטיים האלה, זה בסדר. הנקודה העיקרית שצריך לדעת היא ש
מדידות בכל בסיס תמיד נותנות רק שתי תוצאות אפשריות. 0 או אחד לבסיס Z ופלוס או מינוס לבסיס X.
אם מודדים את המצב אפס בבסיס Z, תמיד מקבלים אפס.
אבל אם מודדים את אותו מצב בבסיס X, מקבלים תוצאה אקראית, או פלוס או מינוס, כל אחד עם סיכוי של 50%.
אז Alice עשויה להכין מחרוזת של qubit-ים כזו, כשכאן זה הרצף האקראי של
אפסים ואחדות וכאן זה הרצף האקראי של X-ים ו-Z-ים. אז האלמנט הראשון בכל אחד מ
שני הרצפים שלה היה 0 ו-X. אז זה אומר שהיא תכין את ה-qubit הראשון במצב פלוס וכן
הלאה. אחרי שהכינה את כל מצבי ה-qubit-ים שלה, Alice תשלח ל-Bob את ה-qubit-ים האלה ו-Bob יבחר באקראי בין X
ו-Z כבסיס שבו למדוד כל אחד. אז עכשיו מוסיפים כמה שורות ל
טבלה כדי לייצג את הבחירות והמדידות של Bob. אז הנה המדידות
ובחירות הבסיס של Bob. והנה תוצאות המדידה שלו של ה-qubit-ים ש-Alice שלחה לו. לבסוף, Bob
יכול להמיר כל מדידה לביט באמצעות אותה טבלה ש-Alice השתמשה בה כדי להכין את ה-qubit-ים שלה. כשהוא מודד את
מצב האפס או הפלוס, הוא מקצה ערך ביט אפס. וכשהוא מודד את מצב האחד או המינוס, הוא שם
אחד. אז מחרוזת הביטים הסופית של Bob היא השורה האחרונה הזו.
שימו לב שכשהבסיסים של שלב ההכנה של Alice ושלב המדידה של Bob תואמים, אז הביטים שלהם יתאימו
גם. אבל אם Alice בוחרת להכין ב-Z ו-Bob מודד ב-X או להיפך,
אז הביטים המתאימים של Alice ו-Bob לא בהכרח יהיו זהים. אז, דרך ששניהם יכולים להסכים על מחרוזת ביטים
לפנקס החד-פעמי שלהם היא להתקשר אחד לשני ולספר באילו בסיסים השתמשו לכל qubit.
כשהבסיסים תואמים, שומרים את הביט וכשלא, זורקים אותו.
אז, במקרה הזה, Alice ו-Bob שניהם יסכימו על מחרוזת ביטים של 0 0 1 0
0. איך התכנית הזו מגנה מפני מצותתים שלא מבחינים בהם? ובכן, בואו נראה מה קורה כשמצותתת כזו
בשם Eve מיירטת את ה-qubit-ים ש-Alice שולחת ל-Bob. היא לא יודעת באיזה מצב ה-qubit-ים האלה נמצאים או איך
Alice הכינה אותם. אז, הודות לעקרון אי הוודאות ולמשהו שנקרא משפט אי השכפול, היא לא יכולה
פשוט ליצור עותק זהה של ה-qubit-ים כדי להעביר ל-Bob. אם היא הייתה יכולה, היא הייתה מצליחה
לצותת בלי שיגלו אותה. במקום זאת, היא מנחשת בסיס שבו למדוד כל qubit, מודדת אותם, ואז
מכינה סט חדש של qubit-ים מזויפים לשלוח הלאה ל-Bob. יש דרכים ערמומיות יותר שבהן Eve יכולה לנסות
ללמוד על ה-qubit-ים, אבל אף אחת מהן לא עוקפת את עקרון אי הוודאות.
אז, פשוט נניח את השיטה הישירה הזו של ציתות Eve. הנה טבלה שמתארת
את ההכנה של Alice, היירוט של Eve, והמדידה הסופית של Bob. אז עכשיו כש
Alice ו-Bob מדברים בטלפון כדי להשוות את הבסיסים שלהם, הם יחליטו לשמור את הביטים האלה למפתח שלהם, אבל
הביטים לא תואמים. זה בגלל ש-Bob מדד qubit-ים ש-Eve הכינה, לא את ה-qubit-ים המקוריים של Alice.
אם הם ישוו תת-קבוצה של הביטים במחרוזות הביטים שלהם, הם יראו שחלקם לא תואמים ו
יניחו שבטח היה מצותת. אז מכיוון ש-Eve נתגלתה, Alice ו-Bob יזרקו
את מחרוזות הביטים שלהם ויתחילו את הפרוטוקול מחדש. אבל אם Eve לא הייתה מאזינה ותת-הקבוצה של
הביטים ש-Alice ו-Bob השוו הייתה תואמת, אז הם יכולים להמשיך ולהשתמש בביטים שנשארו שהם לא
השוו כמפתח המשותף שלהם. ברגע ש-Alice ו-Bob יש להם מפתח משותף, Alice יכולה לשלוח הודעות מוצפנות ל-Bob, ו
Bob הוא היחיד שיכול לפענח אותן באמצעות המפתח. עכשיו שעברנו על הפרוטוקול, בואו ננסה אותו על מחשב
קוונטי. יש כמה דברים שצריך לזכור לגבי הניסוי הזה. ראשית,
BB84 באמת שימושי רק אם Alice ו-Bob רחוקים אחד מהשני. בניסוי שאנחנו עומדים לעשות, Alice
ו-Bob נמצאים על אותו שבב קוונטי. אז, הניסוי הזה לא יהיה שימושי להחלפת מידע פרטי, אבל זו
עדיין הדגמה קונספטואלית טובה של BB84.
שנית, למחשבים קוונטיים אמיתיים יש רעש. אז גם אם בסיס ההכנה של Alice תואם את בסיס המדידה של Bob
ולא היה מצותת, עדיין יש סיכוי קטן שהם ימדדו ביטים שונים בגלל שגיאות ב
מחשב הקוונטי. כשהם משווים את מחרוזות הביטים שלהם כדי לבדוק אם יש מצותתים, הם צריכים קצת סובלנות לשגיאות לפני ש
הם מסיקים שבטח מצותת התעסק איתם והם זורקים את כל המפתח. עכשיו עם ההסתייגויות
האלה, בואו נתחיל עם ניסוי בלי מצותת. קודם כל, אנחנו מייצרים באקראי
שלוש מחרוזות ביטים שונות, כל אחת עם 20 ביטים. הראשונה היא מחרוזת הביטים הראשונית של
Alice. השנייה היא רשימת הבסיסים שבהם Alice תכין את ה-qubit-ים שלה.
כאן בחרנו אפס לייצג את בסיס Z ואחד לייצג את בסיס X. הרשימה האחרונה היא הבסיסים שבהם
Bob ימדוד כל qubit. בהתבסס על שלוש הרשימות האלה, אפשר ליצור דיאגרמת circuit עם הוראות ל
הכנה של Alice ולמדידות של Bob. כל ה-qubit-ים מתחילים במצב אפס. אז כדי להכין את ה-qubit-ים שלה ב
בסיס Z, Alice או לא עושה כלום למצב אפס או מפעילה NOT או X gate שמוצג כקופסאות הכחולות עם X
למצב אחד. כדי להכין בבסיס X, היא מפעילה או Hadamard gate שלוקח אפס למצב פלוס
או NOT gate ואחריו Hadamard כדי להכין את מצב המינוס. אז היא שולחת את ה-qubit-ים ל-Bob. הסט הבא של קופסאות
ב-circuit מייצג את המדידות של Bob. כדי למדוד בבסיס Z, הוא לא צריך להפעיל עוד gate-ים.
הוא פשוט מודד, מה שמוצג על ידי הקופסאות האפורות האלה. כדי למדוד בבסיס X, הוא קודם מפעיל Hadamard ו
אז מודד. נריץ את ה-circuit הזה באמצעות Qiskit runtime primitive sampler. והפלט הוא מחרוזת הביטים של המדידות של
Bob. אז אפשר להשוות את מחרוזות הביטים של Bob למחרוזת הביטים הראשונית של Alice ולזרוק את הביטים
שבהם הבסיסים שלהם לא תאמו. ואנחנו רואים ששניהם מקבלים את אותו מפתח.
זכרו שזו חומרה אמיתית אז מדי פעם יכול להיות ביט שאמור להתאים אבל לא. במקרה הזה כל
הביטים תואמים אבל אם תריצו את זה שוב בעצמכם יכולה להיות שגיאה אבל כל עוד הנאמנות קרובה לאחד
Alice ו-Bob יכולים להיות בטוחים למדי שלא היה מצותת. עכשיו בואו נראה מה קורה אם Eve מיירטת את
ה-qubit-ים. עכשיו יש לנו שני circuit-ים. הראשון מראה את ההכנה של Alice ואת היירוט והמדידה של
Eve. הבא מראה את ההכנה של Eve של ה-qubit-ים המזויפים ואת המדידה של Bob. אנחנו
יכולים להריץ את ה-circuit-ים האלה כמו קודם, ואז לראות מה Alice ו-Bob היו מקבלים כשהם משווים את מחרוזות
הביטים שלהם. הפעם הם מקבלים נאמנות של 6 חוזר. זה הרבה יותר נמוך מ
מה שאפשר להסביר ברעש של המחשב הקוונטי. אז הם מסיקים ש-Eve ציתתה. מחשוב קוונטי
ידוע ולעתים קרובות מקבל הייפ על הפוטנציאל שלו לפתור בעיות קשות. אבל תקשורת וקריפטוגרפיה קוונטית
לעתים קרובות מקבלות הרבה פחות תשומת לב למרות שהפוטנציאל שקוונטום יכול להציע בתחומים האלה הוא באותה מידה
משמעותי ומרגש. היום דיברנו על הפרוטוקול הראשון שהתגלה להפצת מפתחות קוונטית שהוא
כמעט חסין לציתות בלתי מזוהה. אם אתם רוצים לנסות לשלוח קוד בלתי שביר עם
מפתח מאושר קוונטית, לכו למודול שמקושר בתיאור.
תודה שצפיתם ונתראה בפעם הבאה.